all rise for the honorable judge
ethan klein this episode is sponsored
by honey
thank you bailiff officer klein please
have a seat
everybody please be seated thank you for
joining us today
to another uh session of content courts
uh today we analyze the antics of
tick tick-tock pranksters pranks as you
know on youtube used to be rampant and
they were all
set on probation they fled criminal
prosecution
to tick-tock where they now are
basically committing the same atrocities
they wanted on youtube
openly on tick tock this court
is going to hear the cases
and try these offenders
we have on charge today kobe person
logan paul mo bradberry
papa john twist
vitale all the usual suspects except
papa
an unusual suspect
and um well we're going to hear the
cases obviously from our prosecutor a b
and the defense attorney ai ian
and i will declare this court is now in
session
prosecutor will you please make your
opening statement
thank you your honor ladies and
gentlemen of the court we know that
youtube can be a very strange and
bizarre place
if it wasn't for youtube the world may
have never heard the term mommy makeout
day
if it wasn't for youtube the world may
have never heard the song
every day bro we may in fact have never
heard a disney channel flow
and it wasn't for youtube we have not
known of jstation ordering gay potion
from the dark web at 3am
see it is actions like these that
require us to
take action against this type of content
and in the past creators such as
yourselves your honor and bailiff and
creators like idubbbz have stood against
this type of content and these creators
have somehow
migrated to tick tock so once again we
must
shed light on them and we must take
action
thank you prosecution defense would you
like to make opening statement
all right let's cut the crap here
i got a question right at the gate we're
we're
attacking these people based on their
tick tock content correct
we are not attacking anyone ain i resent
the uh implication uh i've i've been
watching your tick tocks ethan do you
really have any jurisdiction over there
i have your i'm not committing pranks uh
ai in we are here to assess
pranks at what point are we prosecuting
your tick tock
is that on the back again i would remind
you to stick
to the order order order what
what my text talks the content of my
tick tocks
is not an question here i will remind
you and
please stay focused strike this from the
record
please um zach the court recorder
ai ian stick to the topic prankster tick
tocks please and i will remind you you
can be held in contempt
please proceed i mean at the end of the
day i think these guys they post cool
stuff
slick stuff some of them on trial
particularly
raw stuff so if this is truly
conversation then i just say you know
let that thing begin baby
[Applause]
okay we have our opening statements
who's applauding order order order in
the court
oh that's hot order who what
who is it in the damn courtroom
fortnite all right k-pop
kobe person is being charged today
with serial cringe while on probation
from youtube
and prank fraud in the first degree
let us proceed with ex the first exhibit
oh so kobe person has been doing this
thing where he buys fruit
this is his tick tock thing oh i guess
we can't listen to music but you don't
need it anyway
he just he cruises up to fruit stands
and pretends to buy all their fruit
it's weird as hell bro the description
is we need more kindness
in the world so he walks up how much for
all the oranges
500 bucks had it okay here's 500.
i don't want your oranges loser
he does have that kind of vibe like he's
like okay buy a loser
yo what is this shirt he's wearing
like seriously kind of thing you do need
to button it up all the way
so do you think he came back and got the
500 back or he just gave him one
he's like all right give me four the 400
back you can keep one you know what i
mean
and tag you on tick tock because you can
tell the way it started
yeah i'm gonna tag you uh 31st and uh
fourth uh fruit orange truck
um watch how he walks up you can tell
it's like a false start like they're
like
and go his shoelaces are untied
that's a look you know you're just way
behind all the times i can't get over
how much he looks like a wee avatar
with the eyebrows and the hair and [ __ ]
you know what i mean
like oh yeah he's whoa it looked like he
had something dragging on his
face looked like he had a zip tie
dragging on his foot
anyway this is obviously fake and i
wouldn't be surprised if they gave him
400 back i'm dead serious
you know take a look at his left foot it
wasn't a sh it looks like a zip tie
oh is it like an off-white thing no i
think he just picked up some trash from
the
street it got caught on his ship anyway
i mean this is fake right
we're not debating if this is real or
not the woman doesn't seem very
impressed
no in the kit well well
okay next let's not linger on this too
long
we've got many more kobe persons so
uh here's another fruit buying video
just because
in his series of fruit buying videos
because you know you know
oh so he goes up let's see the caption
is they deserve more
but i gave them all i had
here's a hundred okay let me start over
from the top here
yeah they all seem super confused how
much do you make per day selling fruit
losers a hundred bucks
he's like all right [ __ ] that's nothing
to me like are you gonna report to the
iraq that's nothing to me freak
take this and move out of my
neighborhood
i want you and your daughter to take the
day off that's not happening they're
already there
at the fruits she's like sure sure yeah
yeah okay yeah we'll take the day off
what's happening whatever yeah
he's like no i need you to clear out i
don't think it's fake though
well i'm fake as i mean it's not candid
it's yeah but i do genuinely think he
asked him to give 400 dollars back
the first one i think you're being
generous this is all the fars
right i wouldn't be surprised if you
only gave him 20 bucks to be honest
no that's too cold even for kobe i
refuse to believe that
because he probably was just like here
keep one of the bills
you know are you crazy are you out of
your mind
who could forget that classic anyway so
that's the his fruit stand series
kobe proposes to a girl so he's
proposing
oh the girl proposes to him
this one was super confusing he slaps it
out of her hand
and turns his back wait what yeah
the girl proposes to me so she gets on
her knees she proposes to him
right and then he literally
slaps out of her hand and turns his back
what is the meaning
i mean you would expect the description
to give some here maybe it's the
the context of the song let me play this
just a short
nope
well the only thing i can maybe guess is
that he was trying to create a viral
moment of like
of a guy who's like [ __ ] this girl
it's quite unexplainable though and
terrible does a b maybe have contacts
that we're missing a b
do you have any context no i don't think
anyone could explain the context of
kobe just one of his scenarios that
makes no sense
he's just he's a badass that's all there
is to it i guess
bailiff do you have any comments on his
physique he is quite
he is quite in good shape i noticed that
he also made an effort to not wear a
shirt so that we would have to comment
on that
um yeah he's definitely focusing on the
top half of his body do you think he
skips leg day a little bit
but um yeah i mean what can i say
are you saying this i didn't say i'm
into it he's in shape
good for him talk to me baby
ela interesting would you buy his fruit
would you buy all of his fruit for the
day no i tell him to take the day off
i will take him i will tell him to take
the day off hey take
the whole month forget about it here's
100 bucks take care of yourself
take the day off here's 100 bucks
all right here he is
dude i don't get this what's with the
height the super
i'm saying start stopping okay this this
is a baby right here
take the baby i'm sitting put them down
babysitting
oh wow okay let me show you something
this is a kid
this is my knee kick me
let me show you something this is a baby
right here
take the baby half a million likes by
the way put them down
babysitting watch he dips on the kid and
the kid falls
and he left that in he they didn't this
is my knee kick me
watch this kid he literally dips on him
and he fall eat [ __ ] on the concrete put
him down
babysitting look at him watch him he
trips
and here he freaks out because he's on
the top of the car this isn't he runs
away
hit me don't leave me here let me show
you something this is a baby right here
yeah take the baby i'm sitting put them
down
on i mean half a million likes is pretty
brutal well
yeah i was gonna say what if you could
tell me the views on this uh av
please go ahead bailey i was gonna say
at least there's an attempt here at
comedy
you know this might be a prankster type
of comedy so maybe it's not for our own
taste but half a million likes
somebody is liking this thoughts on the
baby eating [ __ ] on the asphalt as a
mother
i don't think it was that bad oh really
yeah i'm putting him on the car though i
don't know if i would do that
i just love that they didn't reshoot him
and the babies just falls over
and then and he's obviously doing this
which means he's uncomfortable
yeah he could have easily tripped and
fell off it's a prank bro
do we have views on this uh uh ab i'm
sorry
i can't check on desktop i'm loading up
right now like
what does that mean on my phone you
can't check it on the desktop how many
views
yeah well if it has half a million it's
got to have sev
several million likes for sure or
million views
you know i love that you had to do it
with the lambo as well
it has a three million views 4 million
views your bailiff
when you walk in the room and see bae on
the bed
oh i love his tick tock is sword i have
to refresh it every time
i love his fashion i mean does he own
anything with sleeves bro he's literally
dressed like a
like a uh chippendale stripper
you know what i mean like a hooded
sleeveless
jacket anyway this one doesn't make any
sense again
he says when you walk in the room and
see bae on the bed
what's with the dabbing
do you know what i mean no idea can you
make any sense of this
well here it is for your viewing
pleasure next
kobe harass is another tick-tocker oh
maybe it means like
she's on the bed so he's like okay let's
go
yeah that's it's really you should have
jumped on the bed or something
i don't know that you want to do a dab
before you're going to go in bed yeah i
don't think that's helping anybody
no hey baby you want a i'm trying to
turn you on
dab yeah i dab on ila every time before
we make love
i go you ready you ready to conceive
oh this one was the most perplexing of
all the ones he made
um go ahead and watch this he runs into
another tick tocker
hey what's up you johnny valentine big
fan
so i'm at a restaurant right now and
this tick tocker named johnny valentine
is here and everyone keeps coming up to
him so i'm a big fan also i'ma say hi to
him
hey what's up you johnny valentine big
fan
so this one's definitely set up
right i don't know because the other
tick talker is
like pretty famous i guess i clicked
over and he does have a lot of views and
stuff
i don't think people are going up to him
in restaurant though you know what i
mean
i think somebody's talking you think
they collabed on this
yeah but why would i don't understand
when they do this like why would you
want to portray yourself as that's
such a dude
like he looks like such a douche doesn't
he
ten is here and everyone keeps coming up
to him so i'm a big fan also i'ma say hi
to him
hey what's up all right uh kobe person
we will start with a i n and defense
the charges i will remind you are serial
cringer on probation from youtube and
prank
fraud and the first degree ian
oh okay i mean uh all right yeah well uh
i mean i'm i'm
waiting to hear from the uh the orange
lady
when is she uh taking the stand
we she's not taking the second oh oh
wait she
oh oh wait she's not here
oh well then how do we know this is a
fake prank
right well there's no hard evidence i
mean
and let's say it is a real prank i mean
orange you glad
he gave her some money
speechless i rest my case
and on the charges okay all right and a
b
do you have a response to that do how do
how do we know
it's fake frankly speaking the the uh
any of these
i mean fake or not i think the real
crime is in the cringe and you know i'm
sorry if this comes off a little hard
your honor but
after watching these videos i think god
may have taken the wrong kobe this year
that is very harsh hey b that is
that is extremely harsh i have to say
i have made a ruling on that comment way
too soon
i apologize eject him get the [ __ ] out
baby do you have any other uh arguments
besides this very
tasteless joke just that whether it's
real or not it's just the cringe is the
real problem i believe
the fact that he's trying to look like a
hero by recording himself giving this
lady money
now we're changing the charges mid-trial
we're cheap what what are we doing here
no
another
one of the pieces shown was him knocking
a hat off of that man
who he did say he was a big fan of now
i took a second look at the footage and
i think that what he was trying to do
was actually help him
i would like to direct all of your
attention to a zoomed and enhanced photo
taken okay
he had a spider on his hat
kobe was trying to remove the bug
he was doing a public service i didn't
catch that huh
should i open the tick talking
evidence yeah i mean you understand that
doctoring evidence is a federal offense
i have access to the world's information
and photo enhancing technology you
humans will not
arrive to for at least 30 years
so you cannot you cannot refute this
it is foolproof i i
i am accepting the evidence of the court
thank you a.i.a
okay let's review we've got the fruit
pranks or the fruit savior we can call
him
on that one i personally am not
convinced it is fake
however there was one comment in there i
did not appreciate is when he told the
lady
to take the day off tomorrow hey forget
about such a big shot
such a big shot take the day off forget
about it like hey you just gave her a
hundred dollars
like you're set for life what was it 500
no that that one was a hundred yeah
so the other one yeah i think she's
still gonna go to work tomorrow say take
the day off
all right gabish wrap it up
yeah well the in the first one when it
gives her 500
it's clearly set up whether they agreed
in the beginning or not because
there's obviously a moment where there's
like okay and go
obviously we have no proof i mean that
might just be because you asked for
permission to record
right well we'll never know the truth
and the other one he
the girl proposes he strikes the ring
from her hand
um he's got the baby in the lambo child
endangerment really another charge
a serial cringer on probation
you know when i look to videos like the
dabbing
and the proposal video i have no
question in my mind that i have to find
kobe person
absolutely
um i i feel like for
serial cranger we have seen way worse
i just have to put it out there well
we're not we're not questioning the
severity or the notoriety
i mean certainly one murder doesn't make
you
less of a murderer you know just because
someone has murdered someone
more frequently or more gruesome but
granger has a scale it's not really like
murder or not i mean we all are kind of
cringy
aren't we
[Music]
well when you so but like how do you
decide if someone's cringe i mean
clearly
there's a threshold it's like do you get
those chills in the back
right like i i can't i don't want to
watch it you didn't
find the dabbing cringe a little bit
and you didn't find the proposal
knocking out of the hand cringe
yeah a little more so where are we so do
you know what i'm saying like where's
the threshold
did we pass the threshold or and
remember
i guess for me still on the defense
because there was an attempt at
comedy which while i did not find it
funny i appreciate the
the new thing i think you just want to
[ __ ] kobe to be honest
i i think i need a motion to dismiss ela
for
having a a bias
yeah how's it called what's the legal
term like a
conflict of interest right i think we
have a conflict of interest in this
court
all right because i questioned your
motives
like when you for example said oh this
one's not bad when he was doing
the babysitting one and the baby ate
[ __ ] and he left the baby on the car and
the jokes were terrible and he did it in
a
ate [ __ ] the baby like it happens to
tear it around okay forget about the
baby
forget about the baby what about the
jokes and the lambo
yeah the lambo the lambo definitely adds
on the cringe meter actually
which i did not factor in
[Music]
so that may have helped me right now
i think you know what i think you're on
the
charge of serial crit thank you bailiff
i will make the decision now it is my
courtroom
[Laughter]
on the charge of serial cringe on
probation from youtube
and prank fraud in the first degree we
find
the defendant kobe person
not guilty not guilty
on all charges the court finds that
there's no way to prove that
any of these pranks are fake given that
he is a fruit god and
there's no way to know if he took the
money back or not so obviously this
court
was ruled by law and facts and evidence
on the uh charge of cringe i found the
bailiff
ila's arguments persuasive enough to
put into question my my my reasonable
doubt
and so on those terms i find uh kobe
person
not guilty he's free to go here
free to go incredible logan paul comes
up on tick tock
we know emily love him
he's being charged today with serial
douchebaggery
[Music]
and child endangerment and prank
fraud in the first degree you good bro
let's start with feeding the homeless
which as you guys may know if you've
been following us is a trend
that's been going on on youtube
back in the day was really popular so
here they're stuffing a piggy with cash
and they go up to some homeless girl now
here here's here's my issue with this
video here let me play the audio
for me just got music but yeah
so he goes so here here's my issue with
this video
he doesn't ever even get out of his
[ __ ] gym
well now he gets out and it's just
stuffed with like hundred dollar bills
there's probably twenty dollars in there
you know what i mean so those are one
dollar bills
he approaches this homeless woman
he doesn't get out of his g wagon i mean
it's crazy isn't it then he makes her
hit it with a hammer as if
i don't the whole thing seems very
self-serving to him
could have given her more than like 20
bucks
but the way that they make her
participate with the hammer and how he
does
he's he's that he's in his yeah the shot
from the g
wagon is um next hey homeless lady
come over here and slam this pig with a
hammer you get 20 bucks
like i changed your life hey you noticed
those rims though
hey did you notice those rims girl it's
uh aftermarket
yeah i mean i mean bro yeah i'm good
thank you what was that in reference to
that was that a covet thing
or he said that to me i don't remember
also i have an issue frankly with the
pig emoji they show a pig emoji when
they give the piggy bank like
i get it they're both pigs why well why
are you adding the emoji what really
does that add
good point right they're not she took
her mask off they're really close
oh [ __ ] well look yeah you know i have
problems with how logan does his podcast
they sit across from each other
it's outrageous yeah why is he not
wearing a mask
so here's the thing so he's not wearing
it even when he got out of the car
when he got oh my gosh he's basically
just breathing out of her nose
oh my gosh to a homeless lady and then
he's going to go
do impulsive and sit like two like one
foot away from his guests
you know oh
if i was sick that guy would remove any
content
like that yeah well it's owned by china
they want us to perish
tick tock is a an elaborate uh
tool of china to destroy american
culture
and democracy isn't it owned by walmart
now
is that the deal just the i think
actually i don't know if it's been
finalized but yeah they were
negotiations i don't think they
finalized we
are but it's too late they've already
corrupted
well mark anyway so that's number one
i think a very compelling uh piece of
evidence
number two there's only two examples
here oh the first one was plenty
uh interesting so here is number two
oh it's got music so he um
first of all tick tock was forced to add
a warning
after he posted it saying the actions in
this video
could result in serious injury and the
reason of course being is that
in all likelihood this is completely
edited because of course it's extremely
dangerous to
do that and they would never put
themselves at risk the danger of course
is that kids are going to go try this
who think it's real and how do you think
you could
edit that because it looks like one shot
well jake paul has an exactly the same
video
and i think it's shot very suspiciously
how he creeps back
into the frame oh i think it's one i'll
tell you exactly how they do it
they get two shots one of him without
the car
one with the car and then they supplant
they
combine it so it looks like the car is
going over him
and then here you can see there's a
little bit of weirdness when he gets
picked up
i think they started they brought the
car in
i think him being dragged is real right
so then they started it from there
and he gets dragged just a little bit
down the street
uh so that's how i believe they did it
because it's just it's way too there's
no way i mean it's just way too
dangerous
and uh in the way the car is moving
well i believe that it's possible the
car shot was never changed
what they probably only ever changed was
his frame
him holding on to the back you know what
i mean they did it twice with the car
but do you see how the shot changes
there it moves
he goes totally out of frame can you
zoom in on it
he goes tall here well she goes totally
out of frame
gone then the camera moves the heart is
not related
well because they can do a cut there
jake paul has an exactly the same video
and i think it shot very suspiciously
how he creeps back
into the frame i have submitted a video
um
to the doc above um that's a video of
jake's where he's doing a green screen
effect
they got some pretty good green screen
guys uh
okay let's see that can you show me the
one that jake did
yeah yeah because i feel like jake will
do it worse
he did do it worse well jake was jumping
jake was jumping over the car
oh so they're they're on like a tread
like a green screen treadmill
right oh man
yeah that's a really good green screen i
think with anyone who has like
even a moderate ability in after effects
could could make that look good
okay so that's it there's only two well
your honor uh
we'll have to come back to this after a
recess because it is uh time to go to
okay let's take a quick uh break to
thank our
there are sponsors in this court only
once it's gonna be very quick so please
watch it
and when we come back we will give a
verdict on logan paul
and now a word from our bailiff please
ela proceed
these days it feels like online shopping
is the only shopping we really do
that's where today's sponsors honey
comes in
it's the free browser extension that's
covers the internet for promo codes
and automatically tests them when you're
checking out it's basically your
online shopping best friend how does it
work
you get honey on your computer for free
it's too easy clicks
when you're checking out on one of its
over 30 000 supported sites
honey pops up and all you have to do is
click apply
coupons wait a few seconds as honey
searches
for coupons for that site if honey finds
working codes it will apply the best one
to your cart
wow and i can personally
attest that i do that all the time and
it works
thank you bailiff for the anecdote honey
has found
it's over 17 million members over two
billion dollars
in savings honey supports all kinds of
retailers from tech
and gaming sites to fashion or even food
delivery
it's simple if you have a computer honey
should be on it
it's free and works with whatever
browser you use
you can get honey for free today at
joinhoney.com
h3 what's the coupon on the screen
this is from when i was shopping at
levi's
111 bucks off 223 yes and that's
real um i just they always have like
a lot of coupons going on i think it's
like you know how sometimes they have
like really obscure coupons on sites
they're like fifty percent off for just
like this one specific mailer yeah
he's like [ __ ] you i'm taking that code
because someone with honey used that
code so they're like i'm taking that
code
and giving it to everyone so ela is at
checkout and then all sudden honeys be
like i got you doug
i got this exclusive 50 off code look at
this this is ridiculous savings
yeah we save money all the time on honey
that's it what's the code again
so uh please go to joinhoney.com
h3 thank you honey for supporting
today's episode
thank you bailiff the court is now
back in session
on the count of serial douchebaggery
and child endangerment and break fraud
in the first degree a
in do you have a defense for your client
logan paul
so all right first i would like to
define the word serial
upon looking at the definition it says
consisting of forming part of or taking
place in a
series now i'd like to ask how many
number
how many numbers would it take to
constitute a series
more than i would say five no
three three three now how many pieces of
evidence were submitted to the court
well first of all ain let me remind you
that this is
piggy backing off his already existing
reputation but we are presenting
a certain set of evidence to sway the
courtroom two pieces of evidence were
submitted
and the crime was cereal douchebaggery
you justified sir
cereal being three or more looks like
we've got
the opening showcase here ladies and
gentlemen
this is fraudulence have fun logan bye
there's the door see ya well i find your
argument in bad
faith sir but noted thank you very much
um what about child endangerment and
prank fraud
well also for that one i would like to
cite a uh
little known uh clause in the content
court manual
let me pull it up here we've got the
content
court section b4 d4 s5
which is the badass clause you may not
have been familiar with this judge
the badass clause states that if an
action is badass enough we can nullify
the charge and let the defendant
walk or slide under a vehicle out of the
courtroom
uh-huh i wasn't aware of this clause uh
you're right are those
possibly um watermarks on your image of
the
document oh i clicked the wrong thing
okay interesting um wow the court
does not acknowledge the documents
submitted
nor does it recognize your arguments in
good faith sir
abe yes let me remind the defense
counsel that it is up to the honor to
decide what
uh constitutes for something to be
serial and he has the right to
change his mind if need be also
if we look at just tick tock alone logan
has close to 11 million followers
what are the chances that at least 10
kids aren't going to try to lay under a
car
good point maybe that's all you're on
that's well you'd okay very good point
thank you um thank you both
parties now we will deliberate
okay so this one is obviously as ain
pointed out only two examples but potent
i believe
i agreed now on the charge of the serial
issue i do
i mean i understand his argument but
like
yeah we have to consider his past
defense our courtroom is very
educated fellas and they know fellas
about logan paul's
behavioral issues but i think it's i
acknowledge the technicality and i think
it's a it's a smart play
to you know try to defend
an indefensible person right
now on the count of feeding the homeless
type of video
um serial douchebaggery
i mean from the g wagon
g wagon to the no mask
you got multiple levels of this battery
making her break the pig
giving her like twenty dollars and ones
making her pick it up
did g-wagon push it over for me
yeah hey present break this
pig yeah
okay and then the second one is where
child endangerment and prank fraud of
the first degree come in
the car the car wine i think ab made a
very persuasive
argument the volume of views on that
which was in probably
tens of millions the notion that not
even
one let's just say their chance that not
even
one kid tried it is is is very slight
you know i do think um
and by the way he didn't disclose a
warrant tick-tock was forced to
warn people after he posted it for him
not to put some kind of disclaimer like
this was performed by professionals or
we use the effects
exactly do not attack or do not attempt
this at home or anything like that yes
i feel like it's me it's missing any of
those because
to me it looked pretty real actually and
i i don't understand
editing too it they did it really well
and it's
definitely a badass like ian said
video it looked really cool but you have
to make some sort of a
announcement regarding what is happening
here and what how should people react to
it because you do have a lot of
followers like even
jackass oh yeah you know well because
jackass was working for a network and
they have lawyers and [ __ ] and they
actually know how to disclose
yes properly and when something is real
it's
portrayed as real and you know this is
this is they're in serious pain
afterwards if you choose to do it then
you're at least know what you're getting
into right i feel like this
the fact that it is edited but but
portrayed as real
is a problematic area
this court has come to a verdict
we find logan paul the defendant on the
charges of serial douchebaggery and
child endangerment and prank fraud of
the first degree
guilty on both charges guilty as charged
and we sentence logan paul
to having less followers than his
brother jake
which as if anybody knows is probably
his biggest fear
in life so
that's a hell unimaginable to to him
next up we have mo bradberry of the
e of the uh bradbury brotherhood
the bradberry brotherhood broadway
productions yeah bradbury productions
bo bradberry uh is being charged with
serial cringer on probation from youtube
and prank fraud of the first degree
here we go mo bradberry
i gotta know why i have to re i have to
refresh it every time it never works
mo has a real broccoli assassin
50 cents yeah you know what give me that
take your 50 cent and i'll let you slide
this time
take your apples and get out of here yo
why you did that bro
what's good with you you only gave me 50
cents in 1.20
keep it groovin okay so
this prank misses on so many levels
i think mo thought he was gonna look
like badass
the description is sorry dude you get
what you pay for here's the thing he's
buying
apples the poor guy is like starving
he's buying two apples he's like i only
got 50 cents like he's homeless
hey [ __ ] you i'm gonna eat your apples
obviously mo doesn't work at a grocery
store or that'd be wild maybe
maybe they did fall from grace that hard
but it's obviously fake he almost ate
the sticker by the way
[Laughter]
what are your thoughts did he look
badass here um
no not badass almost at first when yeah
when he was gonna be like okay
you can go but
did you think that was gonna be funny or
what
yeah i think it was supposed to be funny
and badass
but i think this kid just seems like
pathetic and desperate for a couple
apples
you know what i mean so missed the mark
for me
yeah that's that
more bradbury stealing cookies prank
oh yeah this one's fantastic
gotta refresh make sure you have a
recording at all times that right
then how are you doing i'm going all
right um these are the cookies
how could i help you yeah i'm gonna try
these these
yeah check the prices on him man look at
all that
all right thank you hey where you going
yo are these what are you doing with
that [ __ ]
i wanted to show the cookie oh why
didn't you tell me that man
no it's just like playing [ __ ]
cookies man but you can't run like that
make sure you have a recording at all
times right
bailiff so the prank is that
it's really nonsense i mean it it truly
doesn't make sense
he's running out to show it to his
friend why is he running out of the
store
the implication
of course um ai ian can you help me make
sense of this
i mean well first of all
first the kobe thing and then no we're
really comparing apples and oranges here
what sort of cartoon courtroom is this
what is your point i don't get it copy
with the oranges
mo with the apples oh it's fruity is
this a
you know are we running a supermarket
what is this
well yeah huh
okay noted fan uh interesting
also uh you guys have been charged as a
uh for pranks would you call the apple
video a prank
i would call the second one a prank i
will call the first one
like a fringe
yeah i don't even know what though you
call that
no i think it's impressive
go ahead one more time
mo it's a prank bro
ai n
look i've got real evidence here mo was
actually just being
educational i knew this scenario looked
familiar and i had to refer to an old
elementary school textbook
widely circulated throughout the united
states i had a feeling mo was on to
something here
demonstrating to the children and let me
show you an excerpt from that textbook
i've got a page right here
if mo has two apples for 120 and joe has
50 cents how many apples does joe get
the answer two apples minus five bytes
this is taught in schools this is
canon canada this is human canon
human canon curriculum
in elementary schools as we speak wow
hmm that's some legit evidence right
there
if most two apples he gets it for 50
cents well i guess fair is fair in that
regard
don't you remember this old this whole
problem
i don't remember this they teach you
about mo i but i do remember
i do know that you're not human so i
wonder where you're dipping your
experience from
but regardless it is a fascinating piece
of evidence that i will consider
thank you a.b
how do you refute that um well first of
all the validity of that i don't believe
is true
being that part of the guy's head was
cut off in the photo
but also following the premise it just
even following his own premise it
doesn't make sense because
okay he only has half the money so he
should get one of the apples rather than
two but instead he just took a bite out
of both of them
so the premise doesn't make sense and in
referring to
fake pranks if you watch the video again
at the end you could see
a reflection of flash in the guy in the
clerk's eyes when he chased him outside
and he doesn't even acknowledge the
camera even after he's told that
eventually it's a prank he's in on it
he's in on it forget about it
you know i have one more thing to say
hmm
proceed you know
a man why does the robot clear its
throat ain't i always wonder that
i'm processing okay
a man has more than the sum of his parts
you're trying to make a
mixed berry pie with only one berry
the bradberries are like a voltron of
rawness
to judge just one half of the berries
inconclusive
wait where is the raw god
[Laughter]
where is he i call this
an inconclusive mixed trial mistrial
well i actually think aien has a rather
good point and the reason
he's of course referring to ethan
bradbury moe's
brother and we excluded him because his
pranks are
as they say lit
right and what would you like to submit
one to the
to to really consideration ain
well i mean are we going to judge art
now in here
high art no this that is not the
objective of this chord
chase all righty thank you everyone for
your for your arguments we will
deliberate now
mo bradberry serial cringe and prank
fraud in the first degree
[Music]
well i feel like abe made a really
persuasive argument about the prank
fraud i feel like it has to be fake
both of them they are most definitely
fake
is he even trying to hide it is my
question yes of course
yes of course obviously
yes and on cringe
on cringe um hila how do you find
cringe i've seen worse
hmm
seem worse cringe the apples
what's going on here yeah that's in new
york too they're not [ __ ] around over
there
okay so one was december the one in the
store was december
2019. oh that's pretty pandemic
yeah okay that makes sense
the other one is also december 2019.
so we've got the apple biting prank
where he's trying to act like a tough
guy and the more he steals the cookies
you
don't think they're that bad you've seen
worse
kind of mo bradberry
on the charge of serial cringe on
probation from youtube we find the
defendant
not guilty
prank fraud in the first degree we find
mo bradberry
guilty as charged although the court
does add consideration
it's a prank bro yes we the court does
add consideration to the fact that
mo bradberry is a mere a mere
uh seed of himself without the greater
uh ethan bradbury so as ayan pointed out
and so
we are putting him on probation and he
is charged to keep doing his thing and
keeping it raw and keeping it regular
all right about it forget about it huh
come on
our next defendant is a little bit of an
unusual charge
the charge is criminal papa flexing
the defendant is papa john he's been on
tick tock
flexing what some people think is way
too
hard and he even has a tech talk where
he says papa bless or papa flex
where he's like lifting iron and so we
are here today to put papa john himself
on trial here's number one
here he is walking to his private
helicopter he says did you know i have
my own helicopter
and slo-mo jeez yeah
and the song is big papa which you all
know
i love it when you call me big papa
so is this basically this dating profile
now yeah this is kind of
papa's dating profile isn't it tick-tock
i love pizza and i love people
and helicopters i mean we know he's rich
do we
how do we feel about this flexing he
owns a helicopter
it's pretty wild i guess i mean it's
cool that he has a helicopter i guess
there's nothing saying he can't do it i
mean if he owns one
if i had a helicopter would i would i
want to flex it why would i wanna
i don't think hey guys i own the
helicopter i should have owned off
everything
i should show off everything nice i have
been ticked except i don't really have
anything nice i'd be like hey guys
here's my i think the nicest thing i own
is my
iphone that i just bought but how do i
take a
video of my iphone if i have to use my
iphone
camera a mirror ela mirror that's the
answer
do you own a mirror i've lost the plot
officially
next this is totally off the rails pop a
house tour
more papa flexing look at this place man
[Music]
oh you know where does he live in like
kentucky or some [ __ ] he like owns half
the state i believe
he's got his own pop-up ac dc shirt
which we all love
that turns me on ooh i'll do the music
renegade renegade renegade
those columns look like a penis no hate
fitness is extremely important to me
that's why i own 20
treadmills this looks like a policy he
says he modeled the gym after the
bellagio
in las vegas oh i wonder if he has
concubines
damn that's a the view is great too well
of course it is papa
only the best for my boy papo so this is
a megaflex
this house is nuts
stay tuned for part four my god
stay tuned dude has a [ __ ] lake man
okay and like his whole instagram is
just flexing pretty much
here's another one oh this is the the
original
this is him literally flexing for papa
flex
i find it i find it endlessly
interesting that he's selling merch
like the guy he said he's literally
stated he owns a helicopter
now i don't know how much a helicopter
costs to buy but i'm assuming like 20 30
million bucks for a helicopter like that
and he's wearing like some spreadshirt
papa blessed shirt that he's trying to
sell on a website
you know what i mean like god damn papa
yeah he's probably hustling
i mean he's probably making more than we
could imagine just
every minute that he's alive just off of
his money just off his papa johnson yeah
yeah
well you know what's funny this graphic
i recognized someone made it like
yeah before he embraced the meme i feel
like he's just
he's literally just taking images off
the internet and selling i think maybe
for him it's more about the
he likes the he thinks it's yeah he's
building the culture of uh
personality around him yeah he yeah
exactly
he wants to run for president next
probably well if that's the case you're
really gonna like the next one
dude i guarantee you he's thought about
it i
guarantee you and the next one's really
gonna like you're gonna like them
because he cruises up
in his um private jet so he owns a jet
and a helicopter
jesus what do you do with that stuff so
okay i can't play the music but it's sad
does that
so there was a hurricane it was very uh
you know did a lot of damage hurt laura
[ __ ] and he came to see the damage do
you think it's chauvinistic that all
hurricanes have female names or is that
not true
that's not true not true at all oh wow
poison order this is a strike that from
the record
so he visited them so you got to watch
from the top
this is like i feel like this is the
logan paul's g
wagon prank on [ __ ]
times of kajillion
so they're all like uh
what is this meeting it's really long as
well they're all telling him their
damage
they've had to go through i'm waiting
for it to restart with this tick tock so
long let me restart it i can't do this
papa
so here he is cruising up in his private
jet
good way to start good way to look down
on the damage he's cruising in his suit
custom-made suit he's like oh man it
sucks to be poor [ __ ] this
look at this he's like what is this [ __ ]
made of [ __ ] tin
talked to the residents everyone was in
good spirits and trying to stay positive
such incredible bravery in the face of
overwhelming loss
he's walking around there like this is
just a set for him to shine
well papa he's got this god like air you
know i mean he's got that billionaire
thing where he's like you know
yeah like ah it's good yeah
he got here for a reason i made it to a
billion for a reason he goes
i admire the mortals because
the fact that they know they die makes
their life so much more interesting
uh please consider donating yadda yadda
he's meeting
yeah i like so he donated at the end he
didn't say
but i have to hope that he did
he's like i didn't donate i went there
i asked him no i'm sure papa donated
he's a generous soul
papa's a generous soul he just i think
he needs some help on pr to be honest
with you
you know what i mean uh anyway you papa
blessed the city so i'm sure it's all
good now i admire the mortal
life is so much more interesting when
it's all on the line
ah when your home can be blown down by a
hurricane
you enjoy every second of life of
shelter
i admire the mortals that turns me on
god dude who knew you could make so much
money from selling pizza i'm always
shocked by that pizza
man nutritious and good for you what did
they say what's that quote zach
pizza is actually very nutritious yeah
okay so on papa flexing ai in would you
like to
mount the defense for the papa flex
i mean he is flexing but he does a damn
good job with it
it's pure flex and it works
would you really charge that man i mean
look at
look at this man would you look at that
face
and are you an impartial judge here
i don't know that's a really good point
you probably should have refused
yourself you're saying i just charged
myself yeah yeah yeah i might have to
recuse myself
that's a good point but you don't deny
the charge he's flexing
i'm not not
go ahead okay i just want to point out
in the first video i don't know if you
um
called attention to it but he refers to
his helicopter as the papa choppa
wait i'm gonna have to go back to that
because i did not notice the phone like
we can't we're not listening because of
the music and we're missing
out it's not uh it's it's the text that
on screen
yeah but it's like the bottom lower
corner it says
oh it's like a technical overlay
yeah it's gonna come up it's not in the
right in the beginning
i'm looking at the hashtags
i wanna see a tour of the papa choppa
yeah the puppet
i bet you he [ __ ] in the papa choppa no
that's probably why he owns it
so you want to read the hashtags by the
way nature at home
entrepreneur pizza i'm sorry papa but
you can't hashtag pizza on every tick
tock this
has nothing to do with pizza one million
dollar audition
whatever that means money hashtag money
money ain
hashtag motivation hashtag papa john's
papa bless
and vibe check vibe check
yes
any other um any other anything else uh
prosecutor
yeah just one closing point the defense
asks how could we charge a man like this
why would we charge a man like this and
it's because he's so precious to
h3cu if you will he is
has a god-like presence you know we want
to we want to keep it there because
right now he's showing a very human
characteristic of being vain so
we want to just keep him at his
mythological status of being a god
[Music]
papa bless
[Music]
upper let's deliberate
okay papa flexing the criminal it's a
criminal flex is what we're charging him
with really
now aien first of all makes a good point
can i possibly judge him impartially uh
being as that
i'm friendly with papa and i have such a
warm heart
warm spot in my heart for him but the
same could be said for many of the
people we've judged here today mo
bradberry have made his acquaintance
so i'd like to overlook that for the
sake of the show
[Music]
although it's a good argument
um is this criminal flexing do we need
to
protect his image as a god-like figure
in the
h3 world i feel like i
see another issue with papa
and it's something we saw happen with dj
khaled
when a figure falls down the meme hole
too hard
[Music]
yeah i mean gj khaled fell down the meme
hole so hard that he almost fell out of
relevancy because it's like people just
memed him into the [ __ ] when you
start miming yourself i think it's an
issue
once you become aware of the meme it
looks like the chapter and the papa
flicks
yeah um but see is that
is that a charge oh i don't know it's
not a charge it may just be a
we can add a charge meme awareness
meme the meme has become self-aware
well you listen i don't think finding
him guilty
is necessarily going to tarnish his
goblin
status but i will say that in terms of
the criminal flexing
i do charge papa i find him guilty
and i warn papa if you are watching this
as ila correctly noted not to fall
too deep down the meme hole and you
i know you don't know what the hell that
means
but there's someone with you who i met
like your marketing guy whatever does
know what that means
just just ask him what does it mean that
i've fallen too deep down the meme hole
and he'll first laugh but then he'll
explain and he and i think he'll
also agree with us so papa we love you
but we do find you guilty
this is all a farce hey hey order in the
court papa you will accept the verdict
or we will hold you in contempt we'll
come oh [ __ ]
oh papa don't do that to me
now i don't want to be on the day
reckoning list last time he said that
like the people the people his pizza
enemies are dropping dead
like one of the other pizza guys had a
heart attack and [ __ ] i think they found
like isotopes from the russian
government no i'm kidding you know i'm
gonna get you in the papa choppa
yeah i'm gonna pop a chop yacht
all right now now vitali is our next and
final
criminal uh the charges against fatality
is
just straight up crime he's just a
criminal it's not even a meme he's just
a straight up
he's just a criminal he attacked a
female jogger in
april this guy has lost his [ __ ] mind
i'm sure you guys all remember vitaly
he was on like a he was he had to be on
drugs or
or like roid rage they call that
russian youtuber star was arrested
sunday for violently insult
assaulting an unsuspecting jogger in
miami beach
um wait when did this happen in in um
april oh he then straddled the woman and
allegedly punched her on the chest and
face while she was screaming for help
he's very
i don't he got super jacked so i
wouldn't want to take a punch from
vitaly and also he's got crazy rage
the victim played several passer buyers
and residents saw the incidents which
prompted vitaly to run away
the police later arrested him and
charged him for
felony aggravated battery
now this is all did they know each other
apparently she was random it was a
random act of violence
yeah now tmz reports that he posted a 7
500
bond you could just go beat the [ __ ] out
of someone and only get a bond of 7 500
bucks that's shocked me
huh you know what i mean yeah and
apparently he's not even in jail right
now
i mean what youtube prankster has also
had several
prior runs with the law uh in 2016
he was arrested for climbing up the
letter d on the hollywood sign he also
spent five days in egyptian prison after
god
getting caught climbing the pyramids
bro what
oh my goodness i have a big ball
so vitaly is certifiably insane and just
a straight-up criminal
and so when we take all that into
context you'll understand his tick-tock
pranks are extremely disturbing
and hilarious so here take a look
and and by the way i'll give i'll always
give vitali the credit of saying
they're all real but they're insane
and terrifying and he bleached his
eyebrows as if he wasn't scary enough
he's like i'm going to bleach my
eyebrows and freak these [ __ ] out
and it's at the gym too just to [ __ ]
get off the machine uh yeah we'll call
you back
exactly yeah get off no yes
no you've been on the phone for 45
minutes i have not yes you did i have
two more steps two more sets
okay or two more phone calls maybe if
you start texting with your legs it'll
get a little bit bigger what's your name
man
yeah your legs bigger texting your
doctor he's right here your doctor
what you've been on the phone so that
much you're probably texting your doctor
for steroids
you're playing a [ __ ] video game in
the gym disqualified bro that's game
over
[Music]
is that okay for him to jerk off in the
gym i wasn't jerking off yeah you were
you were [ __ ] playing with your dick
i'm not gonna argue no i'm not gonna
[ __ ] i'm not okay you're beating your
meat let me say in a nicer way have a
nice day
get that sweaty ass out of here
just remember this guy beat the [ __ ] out
of a random woman
you know what i mean like it's just it's
not that funny when you realize he is a
violent
deranged psychopath even without that
it's not that funny it's just kind of
like
well he's really imposing it's too
serious like
like he's not showing any signs of
comedy anywhere he's really imposing
and violent looking and jacked so it's
like it's not
dope he's not even like smiling
afterwards like hey i got you
or you know gotcha hey we're homies
actually this prank did really well i
mean yeah it probably has a million
views or something on it so
blah blah blah so that's number one okay
moving on disturbing
the piece in the library
[Applause]
happy friday everybody yeah
do you have any other recommendations
no i'm just horny my internet doesn't
work at home
declaring emergency
[Applause]
let the record show he's wearing a hat
that says villain
that was his merch back in the day he
would be just wear [ __ ] that said
villain
[Music]
she said yes guys we're getting married
i'm getting missed
[Applause]
i feel like he's some impractical joker
wannabe that's just a total dude i say
there was something just
aggressive about his being like he's
just giving me that vibe
and impractical jokers for example did
something
in that kind of setting that was really
funny so it's not like you can't do that
right i think the funny way yeah i think
the difference is that they're trying to
make each other
laugh people around them are laughing
they're not like scared
or just like scared i think that's the
key they're not scared
well they're yeah and also just vitaly
has this really imposing psycho energy
yeah he does he has psycho energy he's
not a dude you want to ask to be quiet
because you think he might [ __ ] choke
you out and beat the [ __ ] out of you
like he did the woman who was jogging
which he's done so this is his prank in
the library
how did this one do how was this
received by the tick tock community
40 000 likes not insignificant
okay let the the court note that vitaly
also did a bang boss back in the day
where he couldn't get it up
and he sat in the corner while his
friend performed and he just sat there
sadly um
with a flaccid penis jerking off
let the record show that okay
i just love that because he's such an
alpha male but like the one time
he tried to do porn he just sat he
literally got cocked
i think we don't need to go there oh yes
we do
he always just push it way too far right
what's wrong with that it's natural
dude get the [ __ ] away from me i love
his wrist
[Music]
what program are you [ __ ] talking then
go do that elsewhere get the [ __ ] out of
here actually
be nice to me i came up to you nice and
you're getting mad for no no no no no
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah either way
because the [ __ ] thing is
completely inappropriate he
you can't he carries himself like he
hates them and that he's ready to kill
them
and he actually has the ability you know
like he's actually a
a big guy it's not like some silly thing
like you can't just start an argument
with him because he'll actually go there
he'll like
beat you up yeah right and he has a
violent history it's not like if i went
up like i feel like anyone would be like
oh this guy's not
threatening because that looks like a
little chubby little [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] or you can get the [ __ ]
lost
seriously sorry you're five seconds get
the [ __ ] out
dude come on really sorry
[Music]
i can't believe people are still making
content like this you know what i mean
this is like day one youtube [ __ ]
huh
so there you have it farting on
strangers prank
uh fantastic fantastic
i remember when it got cooked on the
bang bro bus though
never forget the court this does not
forget
you just gotta love when the alpha male
gets cuck though because the whole
concept of alpha male is just so toxic
and lame
and these guys just get so [ __ ]
roided out and like obsessed with it
and then he gets cocked on the bang bus
i mean he should have been taking the
dick instead of the girl to be honest
with you eila
you know what i'm saying anyway jesus
zach order
he's gonna come try to kill me now i
know we should cut this i'm actually
you're scared of him yeah i don't want
this you're scared of a tally don't
worry i got him i'll take him baby
i'll prank his ass i'm horrified ela
right he's describing
make a scene prank ali make a scene
[Music]
hey kristen make a scene
[Music]
hey kinsey make a scene
[Music]
[Applause]
pregnant with my dad's baby
[Music]
i hate jackson the most by the way holly
make a scene i don't know what's this
like
this like group of super pranksters
you know what i mean a bunch of
attention [ __ ]
so that uh concludes vitale who did you
hate the most out of that one
i don't know them enough to even have an
opinion
ian you want to take a crack at this one
uh vitaly
good luck
oh oh wait are are we still going
yes well i'm in the parking lot oh oh
[ __ ] um
i mean i don't know it's just a prank i
don't know
i got nothing i'm ready for the weekend
all right me too man
it is it's tuesday by the way yeah
it's uh friday somewhere my dude go
that's not how time works yes it is
maybe
all right take care maybe in the cyber
world all right
we wish you a happy weekend maybe go
ahead not much defense on this one
yeah not much of prosecution either i'm
kind of scared he's going to shake me if
i talk bad about himself oh okay wow
so we have witness intimidation we have
is it the bleach
eyebrows do anything for you or what is
it about him that frightens you
um sort of uh well how he walked up on
joey salads that's good
that's kind of scary oh or hold that up
oh pull up the evidence please oh
let's go
what up guys so i just walked in the gym
and oh my [ __ ] secret
i see joey [ __ ] salads the [ __ ]
always talk [ __ ] about me disrespecting
me
my mother saying he wants my mother says
he wants to [ __ ] my mother
talking all this smack making videos
online
i walked into the gym he glanced at me
he was on the treadmill and now he's
gone
he's gone i don't see him i think he's
in the locker room
let's wait for this [ __ ] douchebag
let's see where he has the same person
he's so crazy what's up bro say hi
what's good what's up i love
you she always trying to show in the
world all the videos you've made [ __ ]
talking [ __ ] about my mom the one video
i made a year ago
yeah now i'll catch you finally in
person what's up what do you got to say
it's youtube
i don't know youtube i'm in front of you
right now what you're going to do about
it you're going to talk [ __ ] about my
life i knew this was going to happen
yeah well it finally happened i was
waiting for this moment to happen
i got to say joey's a softy he's an
idiot he's a
[ __ ] idiot and he got banned for
spreading covet 19 propaganda
but he's a softy you know what i mean
he's not a murderer he's
he's not a murderer like the tower [ __ ]
about my mom have you ever spoken
anything bad about your mom by the way
maybe you shouldn't say that he's a
murderer
oh he's murdered people i may be uh
that may not be wise to say as a judge
but he's murder people
by the way when i when i shook joey
salad's hands i'll never forget he has
the softest hands
it's odd it's just odd i felt it
it's so weird his hands are like it's
just so weird joey
soft hand joey with her boob coming out
right no exactly so why would you
keep it's fine [ __ ] your youtube no it's
not jokes i'm here in front of you what
you're gonna say about it
i gotta say it it's just stupid youtube
people yeah stupid yeah exactly because
you're gonna confront everybody who has
something bad to say about you
oh if i see him in person of course i
will of course i will i respect that
that you'll
yeah [ __ ] you
i'm serious i'll beat your [ __ ] ass
with my right hand while i'm filming my
left
it's not better you [ __ ] disrespected
my mother and you don't disrespect it
maybe in this country again not in
[ __ ] russia i apologize that i
disrespected your mother i didn't mean
it to be disrespectful
i thought i was just happy you said you
wanted my mom fanny all right so i i'm
sorry i'm not i truly am sorry if it
hurt you and i'll i'd like to shake your
hand because i'm sorry i'm good bro
oh look there's a highlight of us
watching this clip
we've never watched it before i think
no we watched it yeah so
vitali is um
is insane
the court finds okay so on the so we're
gonna deliberate now in vitali
the court finds we don't even need to
talk about it
do we what do you mean about his charges
no he's he's [ __ ] up you're scared of
him he that doesn't want to pass the
harsh judgment because he's afraid of
him
i'll say this in vitaly's defense
actually i give vitali this credit
this distinction of distinctions
that nobody else on youtube can claim
and he'll be happy to hear this i think
this is all he cares about
he does not fake his pranks
he's a real one
a real one i hope i never meet
[Music]
that being said this court finds vitaly
guilty of criminal assault
and sentenced to probation uh she's
given a bond of 15 000. oh that's weight
that is the real charge
yeah he's being actually charged right
we sentence him to three years of prison
for criminal
assault oh wait that is the yeah
he's in jail
so there you have it just a little look
back on the pranksters
that was very educational thank you
defense aien who was left for the
weekend already he's no longer here
thank you ab for sticking around at
least till the end
appreciate you for that at least doing
my job
and um thank you everyone else for
watching this court is now
earned dismissed
a journey
you